acusaciones cruzadas por la gestión de
la seguridad Twitter fue escenario de
una polémica entre el presidente del
Salvador nayib bukele y su homólogo
colombiano Gustavo Petro el mandatario
del país andino afirmó el lunes que la
nueva mega cárcel salvadoreña para
retener a pandilleros es a su juicio un
campo de concentración el video llegó a
manos de bukele El miércoles que les
espetó los resultados pesan más que La
retórica deseo que Colombia en realidad
logre bajar los índices de homicidios
como lo hemos logrado los salvadoreños
Dios los bendiga Petro acostumbrado como
bukelea a utilizar Twitter como un arma
política y propagandística de su gestión
aprovechó para recordarle al mandatario
centroamericano que en Colombia también
se ha registrado un descenso de la
violencia homicida pues nayib pasamos de
90 homicidios por cada 100.000
habitantes en 1993 en Bogotá a 13
homicidios por cada 100.000 habitantes
en 2022 no hicimos cárceles sino
universidades es bueno comparar
experiencias Te propongo un foro
internacional por el momento la
discusión terminó con bukele haciendo
gala de su ironía y criticando que Petro
se atribuyera y se logró sin haber
estado en la casa de gobierno la disputa
dialéctica se dio días después de que
llegaran a la mega cárcel conocida como
centro de confinamiento contra el
terrorismo los primeros 2000 presuntos
pandilleros detenidos en el marco del
estado de excepción que rige en el país
desde hace 11 meses el traslado de los
reclusos se dio justo después de que la
fiscalía de Nueva York hiciera público
un acta de acusación en el que se prueba
que el gobierno de bukele negoció a
escondidas con las pandillas desde 2019